ihr wisst dass ich meine glitches leben
alleine hacks und tricks um irgendwie an
geld zu kommen dass man grundsätzlich im
internet geld verdienen kann wissen wir
in den letzten tagen ist allerdings eine
super verrückte idee gekommen wie ich
während dem schlafen im internet geld
verdienen kann und das ganze ist kein
witz funktionieren wird es aber nicht
durch mich alleine sondern nur mit eurer
hilfe was ich vorhabe und wie das
funktionieren sollte erfahrt ihr in
diesen regionen dieses video ist
tatsächlich aus einer idee heraus
entstanden wie ich möglichst viele
spenden für die ukraine sammeln kann was
seine ukraine gerade abgeht ist völlig
unglaublich dass wir kriege in europa
haben hätte ich niemals gedacht und ich
wollte eine möglichkeit finden wie alle
von uns etwas dagegen tun können oder
den leuten dort helfen können auch wenn
das geld bei ihnen vielleicht gerade
knapp ist und genau so ist dieses video
entstanden alles was in diesem video
also passieren wird das komplette geld
was dabei rumkommt geht sofort in die
ukraine und nicht nur dass sobald ich
erstmal alles erklärt habe werdet ihr es
noch verstehen ich werde den betrag
komplett verdoppeln ich bin kein
politikwissenschaftler ich will dass
meine einschätzung gar nicht zu groß
ausgeben das ist unheimlich schrecklich
für alle leute die da sind ich und viele
leute um mich herum befinden sich in den
letzten tagen und wochen in der
absoluten schockstarre und wissen gar
nicht so recht wie man mit der situation
umgeht ich denke an alle von euch die
familie dort haben ich denke an alle
leute die da sind und ich probiere mit
diesem video einfach was gutes zu tun
und euch damit einzubeziehen und die
komplette kraft dieser community zu
nutzen um einfach wirklich vielleicht
ein bisschen was zu verändern und nicht
wundern jetzt wechselt das video wieder
zu einem unterhaltungs video das was ich
kann das ist mein job und ich hoffe dass
ich euch auf ein paar andere gedanken
bringen kann viel spaß mit dem video und
lasst uns gemeinsam was gutes tun
vor einigen monaten habe ich ein video
hochgeladen in dem ich erzählt habe wie
viel geld ich in 20 21 verdient habe auf
das video wurde reagiert erst mal nichts
ungewöhnliches dann habe ich mir
irgendwann beim essen mal die ganzen
reactions angeschaut und geguckt was
meine youtube kollegen oder zusagen oder
vielleicht was sie verdient haben aber
gab es eine person die den rahmen völlig
gesprengt hat aber seht selbst ich weiß
nicht warum wir haben nur gepennt sieben
stunden gestreamt hochgeladen 800 24.000
aufrufe und damit haben wir 2600 euro
gemacht also es ist kein witz 3 max hat
ein video hochgeladen in dem er schläft
das video bekommt 800.000 aufrufe und er
verdient
2600 euro
dass das ist völlig absurd ist muss sich
keiner von euch erzählen ich bin aber
ein bisschen ins grübeln gekommen wie
könnten wir das für uns wie könnten wir
das in der jetzigen situation nutzen und
vor allem wie können wir das auf die
spitze treiben dazu aber erst mal kurz
youtube theorie geld mit youtube adsense
zu verdienen funktioniert dadurch dass
sich zuschauer werbung anschauen wenn
der zuschauer die werbung nach fünf
sekunden weg klickt bekommt man weniger
als wenn der zuschauer die werbung
komplett durchlaufen lässt oder sogar
drauf klickt in youtube studio also wo
youtuber die einstellungen für ihre
videos vornehmen kann man selber
entscheiden wie viel werbung im video
vorkommen soll das bedeutet ich kann
auch wenn ich möchte alle zwei minuten
werbung rheinland was bei hartz stunden
schlaf circa 240 werbung wären und damit
238 werbung mehr als bei troy maxson
wenn ich jetzt also möglichst viele
leute dazubekommen würde sich ein acht
stunden langes video von mir beim
schlafen reinzuziehen bei dem alle zwei
oder drei minuten werbung läuft dann
könnte das ein absolut lukrativer money
glück sein damit das ganze aber
funktioniert brauchen wir vorrangig noch
genau zwei sachen ein video in dem ich
schlafe und zweitens das schwierige
möglichst viele zuschauer die sich
dieses video die vollen acht stunden
anschauen 240 werbungen schön und
ich muss aber leute eben wieder zu
bekommen sie ihr acht stunden lang
einzuziehen wie ich schlafe und alle
zwei minuten währungen und hier geht das
problem so ein bisschen los ich musste
ich euch davon überzeugen das ist geil
ist sich dieses video komplett rheins
ist beim zocken nebenbei auf dem screen
auf lautstärke 1 laufen zu haben wenn
wir irgendwann chillen zeit und
natürlich nicht wenn ihr schlaf sondern
nur wenn ihr aktiv schaut das video
nebenbei auf stufe 1 auf eurem handy
laufen ist die ganze zeit immer wenn ihr
nicht aktiv an einem gerät zeit auf
lautstärke 1 diese komplette video
durchlaufen es muss die ganze zeit
laufen damit ich aber meinen teil auch
noch dazu beitrage habe ich etwas
ziemlich cooles überlegt ich werde den
kompletten betrag der mit diesem
wiederum kommt in den ersten sieben tage
verdoppeln mit einer grenze von 10.000
euro können wir es also schaffen eine
ordentliche summe zusammenzubekommen und
die dann in die ukraine zu schicken wo
sie deutliche nötiger gebraucht wird als
bei uns aber wie zur hölle kann ich mir
überhaupt leisten den betrag bis zu
10.000 euro verdoppelt sehr gut frage
genau das habe ich mich auch gefragt
habe alle meine partner angerufen und
einer war sofort bereit das ganze super
kurzfristig zu unterstützen renault
schickt wie immer muss ich euch nicht
erzählen dass rainer schild so ziemlich
die besten handy hüllen auf dem markt
macht sie wurden unter panzer gelegt sie
wurden aus helikoptern geschmissen ihr
kennt das ganze jetzt gibt es allerdings
eine neue hülle des klubs bei denen es
noch mehr zu customizing gibt als bei
den höhen nicht schon vorgestellt an der
hülle könnte so ziemlich alles ändern
die knöpfe die kamera frames des lenny
hat das übrigens aus 100 prozent
recyceltem plastik ist dann könnt ihr
euch die hülle genauso zusammen was denn
die sie haben wollte youtube ist der
kampagnen titel was ziemlich gut passt
natürlich könnt ihr weiterhin auch alle
verschiedenen designs und prinz auf den
hüllen haben die reine spiel zum angebot
hat also egal ob senders walt disney nbc
oder ganz viele verschiedene andere
designs ihr könnt euch die hülle
wirklich genau so gestalten wie sie
haben ich bin unglaublich stolz und zb
das rennen so schnell reagiert hat und
bei dieses video und diese aktion zu
unterstützen über den ersten link in der
video beschreibung kommt ihr auf der
website sucht euch was aus und gestaltet
durch die höhen sowie sie haben ist
wirklich keine selbstverständlichkeit
ich weiß es sehr zu schätzen und vielen
dank dass sie mich dabei unterstützen
den betrag zu verdoppeln jetzt geht es
weiter im video
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
laut es mir oder glaubt dass wir nicht
hier wurden gerade acht stunden feinster
content produziert mit dem setup des
grauens einfach kamera macbook alles in
obs und dann schön acht stunden lange
aufnahme 300 gb die werden jetzt
hochgeladen und dann hoffen wir mal dass
wir da ein paar erinnern können das
waren die anstrengendsten acht stunden
contentproduktion die ich jemals hatte
jetzt gilt es auch das ganze noch
nachzubereiten das muss noch mal neu
ausgerichtet werden ich lege mucke
dahinter damit die leute wie youtube
premium haben das ganze quasi als low fi
playlisten einfach nehmen können und
mucken dabei hin neben dem zocken und
beim schlafen oder wobei auch immer
hören können und außerdem habe ich mich
gefragt wie nennt man so ein video weil
eigentlich wenn ich den richtigen titel
treffen wenn ich den richtigen nerv
treffen könnte ich auch internationales
publikum bekommen also wenn ich quasi
schreibe des video contains maximum
esposito crane oder irgendwie sowas dann
könnte es sein dass das irgendwie vom
algorithmus mit aufgenommen wird und
daraus irgendwas entsteht ich werde
natürlich das video bei reddit posten
ich werde natürlich alles versuchen um
möglichst viel reichweite darauf zu
bekommen und natürlich hoffe ich auch
auf eure mithilfe aber ganz wichtig ist
eben dass ich leute erreiche die nicht
ich schon meine zuschauer sind am besten
von überall auf der welt dass jeder
dieses video im hintergrund laufen lässt
da weiß ich noch nicht genau wie es
mache ich suche jetzt erst mal mutter
aus die in den hintergrund kommt und
dann können leute das immer als playlist
benutzen so hinter mir seht ihr den
anfang des videos durchlaufen da erklärt
eine englische stimme wie genau das
funktioniert was ich vorhabe damit wir
alle leute abgreifen können wir jetzt
nicht direkt aus dieser community com
ich setze mich gleich mit jemandem
zusammen der plan von red hat und der
count hat der schon viel gekostet hat
und so damit wir das auf reddit
verbreiten können ich werde es natürlich
auf allen anderen social es von mir auch
noch verbreiten und im prinzip heißt es
jetzt rändern video hochladen und darauf
hoffen dass sind irgendeiner weise
funktioniert ich weiß ja gar nicht genau
ob youtube dass nicht alles checkt und
dann gar nichts passiert ich hoffe dass
alles glatt läuft und wir geld
zusammenbekommen dass ich dann
verdoppeln kann und das dann ausgeht
ist sehr cool ich habe gerade über eine
stunde reden pecat in dem video
platziert ist es alles fertig ich lade
jetzt die acht stunden hoch klickt auf
den ersten link in der video
beschreibung lasst das video im
hintergrund laufen ich würde euch
natürlich niemals sagen dass ich beim
schlafen laufen lassen sollte nur böse
zungen würden so etwas behaupten ich
hoffe sehr dass es funktioniert ich habe
keine ahnung ob es funktioniert ich
probiert irgendwie richtig
aufmerksamkeit darauf zu bekommen und
ich hoffe dass ihr mich dabei
unterstützt das ist eine ziemlich
verrückte idee und es kann natürlich
wieder sein dass nichts funktioniert
aber wir hoffen mal das beste über den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
konnte zum video lässt das laufen vielen
dank an rainer schild dass sie mich an
dieses projekt und diese verrückte idee
unterstützen wir sehen uns am sonntag
wieder ich mache mich auf den weg nach
asien jetzt um dort ganz viele videos zu
drehen und jetzt geht es endlich wieder
richtig los außerdem ich habe vielleicht
schon eine wohnung fürs wohnungsumbau
projekt gefunden
[Musik]